there we go do you want to do it
yourself there we go yeah you hear it
but but how how how did this make you
feel like you know made me feel like
time so dark you know we believe in
demons and we believe in like Gins so
you know when you listen to the Quran we
believe this this cures that people say
that this basically a g like within me
do you know what you listen to do you
know what it was and it was thing it was
a thing
Allah just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you was
there we go do you want to do it
yourself there we go yeah you hear it
yeah turn the camera to
[Music]
me yeah you listen to
it
mement okay what what
what let me let me know let me how's it
how does it make you
feel right pause
it can
I how does it make you feel oh do you
know what do you know what you just
listen to yeah I like very much how did
it make you
feel I believe that sound we
[Music]
very but but how how how did this make
you feel like did you know it made me
feel like time so down it made you feel
like time like slow down and I know slow
down they also slow down also okay
interesting do you know what you listen
to do you know what it was and it was
thing it was a thing from Allah oh the
Quran yes you know okay good um have you
read the Quran before sister yes when I
basically do things that are very bad
and if the Crown's around me things
start to shake if the things start to
like things will shake things will shake
really yeah okay so are you are you a
Christian or a all God all gods I
basically believe that is a god you do
believe there's a God okay see
look it's weird
how so you do you do believe there's
multiple gods or one God
um
basically very
fast are you are are you are you have
you been
drinking no basically the problem well
yes but can't lie
yeah but it's to you're
corre it is it is I mean the thing is
this sister like you know through us we
believe there's a bigger purpose to life
and we're here for a reason and uh we
are going to judge we believe that God
is one we don't believe God is a man we
don't believe he's a woman um do you
have a copy of the Quran do you have a
copy like this drink actually so down
that's so weird really that's
interesting so so so things kind of slow
down you could absorb things more did
you noce did you see it as well yeah
yeah because I saw start dancing but
when he came on you
stopped yeah yeah it can be very it can
be used in the wrong way what what made
you stop dancing was it that when you
listening to it it stopped everyone else
say that again it stopped everyone else
really like things around you kind of
slow down did you notice kind of we can
mind if I tell you the translation of
what you're listen to yeah so that was
the Quran it was the speech of Allah God
so you were listen to the speech of God
and he was say saying he spoke I Jesus
in the crib in the in the the Cradle I
am the servant of Allah he has given me
the scripture and appointed uh and has
appointed me as a prophet and made me
blessed wherever I might be and has
enjoined upon me prayer and the giv of
arms as long as I live and he has made
me truthful towards my mother and has
not made me arrogant unblessed peace be
upon me upon the day I was born and the
day I die and the day I am raised to
life such was Isa son of of Mary Jesus
Son of Mary this is the narration of
truth about which they have no doubt so
so to us is that we believe Jesus as a
prophet we don't believe we believe in
his
miracles yeah we're really good you know
you know if you change your life I came
to Islam 11 years ago I was not a Muslim
and it really my my life my perspective
on life has change I used to come
clubing partying in this very spot here
so I believe sister there's a bigger
purpose to life I me of course look you
know people I was living the same
lifestyle you know I never brought me
happiness me what LIF no the LIF I live
like you know like myself I come clubing
party you know I try drinking Etc but it
never me makes you happy because your
soul wants God Almighty your soul wants
have a relationship with God Almighty
that's why if you see our table it says
only in the remembrance of God do hearts
find peace yeah you would only find true
happiness when you have a connection
with God Almighty yeah do you have any
questions for us we don't want to over
see
you can we stop people being big
just one guy that was it everyone's been
lovely like yourself but maybe you can
get one English girl board
say yeah it's very sad like something
yeah this is a gift you yeah you saying
what was
that you know I got put in jail why I
thought I didn't do the C oh well this
is why this is why the day of judgment
is really important and it's lies it's
because of Lies like you know when
people lie to their family
up Li and you got with confusion you see
this is why it's so important that we
believe in a here after because there
are so many people who have been misle
like have been imprisoned who some
people have got execution executed agree
I agree very sad I feel very embarrassed
sometimes to basically be like an
English woman because I feel like
there's some things that like I have got
away with in court and then basically
there's like men or whatever like I
basically like did nine assaults on
police well I didn't believe it was me I
think a demon that jumped into me do you
see when you list like one man and
because he's not English or whatever he
basically got like he got like five
years and it's happened all the time and
I think it's so what do you mean
he got five years for what like for like
like one of the crimes I have committed
like for example like a person of color
or whatever they basically have
literally been put down for like 5 years
and then during that time that leave a
house everything like I think it's awful
it's really do you mean do you mean he
was falsely accused yes like by who well
I don't personally know but I'm saying
it happens time and time again and it's
a it really it's really you know we
believe in demons and we believe in like
Gins so you know when you listen to the
Quran we believe this this cures that
people say that there basically a gen
like within me it can be this this this
is why the Quran you know if you write
if you go on YouTube and write Surah
bakar and play in your house it will
deter this stuff but also you need to
understand sometimes they don't want to
be cured though why
not because I have fun when I go into
anus and if a dress randomly falls off
the hunger and falls into my
back but the thing is ulul Ultimate fun
sister is that you know your purpose you
know why you're here you know where
you're going yeah and the Quran will
give you that ultimate happiness and
purpose uh these you know you want to
live a life of fulfillment with the
Creator drinking partying clubbing drugs
these are never going to bring you
happiness when you when you sober up
when you come to your senses and then
you make that decision of course it's
not going to be easy but when you have
that relationship with God Almighty it
will change your life for the better
even when you listen to the Quran for
like 30 seconds you said things slow
down you stop dancing down exactly why
did you stop dancing because you realize
it's not something to dance something
that I think it's sound waves I think
it's like basically it's frequency
that's fine but how how did that make
you feel you said you know I basically
was just I when that happened I was
basically just um thinking of how it was
going to affect you because I was
basically feeling like oh I don't want
you to be confused that something that
is beyond the like normal spiritual
level can be like foren do you know what
I mean okay cuz that can very confused
people okay interesting yeah no I didn't
have the EXP I just wanted to know how
you felt you know I felt fine I was just
like like prec concerned with like how
it was going to affect no I I'm fine I'm
totally fine you know if you want you
can listen to it more I mean if it makes
you feel better I need to like pop off
but it was very lovely to meet yours not
YouTube thank you s what's your name
Megan Quinn sister Megan nice nice
meeting you but yeah if you have any
questions we're here every Friday and
Sunday and yeah you can listen listen to
the Quran on YouTube open it you know
you can read it in I think we need to
change that basically like you know that
Quran we need to change it so when I was
like 13 14 my grandparents bought a
restaurant in Liv to T right okay and
then I picked up a DVD and then my it
was in um Arabic my grandma was like you
turn to Isis whatever and then
basically no but it was at the time of
that but then basically like following
this like she want me for two weeks
she what she would not speak to me for
two weeks but I was like so you was you
a Muslim you became a Muslim or you was
just listening to this I was a child it
was just a DV I rly picked up but
basically I just think it's wrong how
basically people like the thing is like
there's a lot of knowledge like I I got
ja you know I J like TV channel I
there's so much like it's just I it's
all like um what is the word it's
basically all um
it's all due to your own perception and
I don't like how people get like like
whatever but like I honestly like um to
be honest
like cath Catholicism it's not done very
much good and the most amount of
knowledge I've learned is actually
through like when I was like through ART
L and like that like I wouldn't put
myself into certain thing but I would
just all way have you ever done
meditation I can't because um well
I
um I basically have um two like it's
um I have a lot of businesses that I'm
currently running that are legal and
illegal so basically I'm not fully
compant with Allah but that's fine Allah
doesn't want you to be sinless he knows
you're going to sin but you need to have
a relationship with him so like yes I
pray to God every day okay do you
believe do you believe in Allah do you
believe one God of course are you crazy
I out of a window you can ask man
basically I have fallen out of Windows
four or five times hell I fall
out of Manish tayor like i j to kill
myself literally I have survived death
five times it's actually up
what's what's what's what's made you
want to take your life sister um if you
don't mind me ask cuz I really want I
cuz obviously we don't want the same
thing my own bad mental health okay so
you see this is why it's important
combined with basically like um alcohol
um and things that basically people have
like like um put towards me but um
basically
um okay let me tell you on S I'm to find
no no no it's fine I think you've said
it really well look I I'll be honest you
look I I'll tell you yeah Sin Sin you
know the sins they I always survived and
basic people say to me because God has
purpose for you is it like I don't
believe it's like so yeah know I do
believe it course sister Mega let me
tell you something like look I was
randomly doing this you came out of
nowhere I'm not sister you should a
devil mega no no no I
you're my sister in in in humanity so I
want you to know look Allah God Almighty
do not ever despur his mercy no matter
what sins you've committed you can
always turn to him yeah you know in the
Bible that you know God I think God will
so mean like saving someone piss him off
his his retaliation yeah was so so so
mean right yeah it is in the Old
Testament is quite severe I think he
acted way too severe yeah but you know
Allah subhana say no but I think he
actually very too sever no exactly but
we don't that's the the Old Testament in
the Quran my friend currently like yeah
um he like he has the same but I think
like what the hell like it's so severe
what someone piss you off slightly your
react yeah exactly so in Islam in Islam
I just say what Allah says in the Quran
Allah says that all my servants who have
transgressed against
themselves from France oh wow really
from France what life yeah no no not
live alhamd amazing
so just want to say one thing that Allah
says in the Quran all my servants who
have transgressed against themselves do
not ever despair mer the mercy of your
lord so no matter what sins you have
committed God Almighty is the most
merciful yeah whatever situation you're
in I want you to do one thing for me
yeah if you ever feel suicide if you
ever feel there's no way out if you feel
like there's nowhere to go Allah says in
the Quran I respond to the caller that
calls upon me can I give you a guided
prayer mat yeah you do yeah let me let
me let me let me give you one uh just
I'll get put that in a bag let me put
that in a bag for you sister
come sorry uh can you give me a bag
please yeah of course yeah the bags bag
yeah
where is
she oh there she were you we had the huh
we
yeah yeah she was saying yeah shean told
me so so sister this will teach you like
this is how this shows you a mat it
shows you how to pray if you're ever in
a situation where life gets difficult
things are not make it look we're always
here for you every Friday and Sunday if
you need someone to talk to we'll sit
down I'll get some tea food we can talk
but do not ever Resort to taking your
own life yeah so we are always here look
I'm I'm I I'm at your service I can
bring my wife my wife can talk the
prayer m is there if you ever need to
turn to God I'm alone if you're alone
you know let me tell you something
sister yeah when you the reason why let
me tell you something you can have
millions of friends you will always feel
alone you know why because the only one
that will never let you down is the one
who created you from the moment you was
created to the moment you are going to
die the moment that you live in God
Almighty is always going to be there for
you and just know as your brothers in
humanity we're here for you if you ever
feel like you know what I need someone
to talk to I mean we are here every
Friday and Sunday even if needed be like
I mean if there's any way that we can
help you we are but do not ever feel
like you are bad or God doesn't love God
Almighty wants good for his servants